il se vend 1,7 millions de boîtes de
macaronis au fromage de marque craft
Denner par semaine au Canada c'est la
promesse d'un repas simple peu cher et
prêt en 8 minutes mais il y a de nouveau
joueur sur le marché alors l'épicerie a
proposé à 50 goutteurs et goutteuses des
produits bien sûr il y a le crabe des
mains incontournable une version
biologique anise une version végétale le
gogo quinoa et le nouveau venu les
Cheetos alors du salon de la moto au
Palais des Congrès à Montréal la salade
dégustation
[Musique]
c'est un produit connu réconfortant pas
cher c'est normal qui est plusieurs
marques qui est leur version du macaroni
au fromage même greffe des nœuds et
autre marque Anaïs ont plusieurs
déclinaisons du macaroni au fromage du
crémeux extra crémeux avec toutes sortes
d'autres ingrédients c'est
a été créé en 1937 par un Canadien
jamescraft s'est installé aux États-Unis
à Chicago pour profiter de l'essor qui
avait en ce moment-là dans tout ce qui
était innovation alimentaire pendant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale on vendait le
craft des nœuds comme une façon de
nourrir 4 personnes en 9 minutes c'est
ça le slogan
[Musique]
ça ressemble
notre produit de référence si on veut
c'est le moins cher sur le marché il y a
une courte liste d'ingrédients malgré
tout il y a une teneur en sucre qui est
plus élevé que les autres et on sait pas
trop pourquoi
[Musique]
non non vraiment vous l'avez terminé
donc
c'est moins bon ouais
c'est la marque québécoise dans le Lot
c'est la marque aussi vegan donc
végétalienne sans gluten on a aussi
beaucoup d'ingrédients biologiques une
courte liste d'ingrédients comme le
craft des nudes d'ailleurs c'est le
produit qui est le plus riche en fibres
mais ça va aussi être le produit qui est
un petit peu plus cher que les autres
évidemment ça n'a pas le même goût que
le craft des nœuds qu'on connaît mais
pour quelqu'un qui ne consomme pas de
produits laitiers qui ne consomme pas de
produits d'origine animale ça va
certainement chercher ce petit côté
nostalgique là parce qu'on voit capable
de recréer le goût fromager avec la
levure alimentaire par exemple
c'est sûr que la liste d'ingrédients
tirer mon attention parce qu'elle est
très longue
c'est aussi le plus grand le plus salé
des produits analysés sans surprise je
vais dire c'est quand même à partir
d'une grignotine ce macaroni au fromage
[Musique]
qui est connu comme une marque
biologique de produits de toutes sortes
dont plusieurs produits ultra
transformés on a aussi beaucoup
d'ingrédients biologiques donc Annie ce
qui est presque aussi grave que le cheat
toss les ingrédients quand même assez
longue comparativement à gogo quinoa par
exemple
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est un repas complet non
quand on en mange comme ça pour le
plaisir c'est pas la fin du monde qui
est pas suffisamment de protéines
après si on en mange régulièrement parce
qu'effectivement c'est accessible
abordable et apprécié de la famille ben
oui on pourrait se dire bon on va
ajouter des protéines les protéines qui
sont disponibles parce que dans un
contexte de d'insécurité alimentaire le
macarino fromage en bois peut
effectivement faire partie des repas
régulièrement
alors les choses changent quand il la
compétition ça vient peut-être bousculé
nos habitudes mais justement surprise
parce que c'est le nouveau joueur de la
marque Cheetos qui a été le favori de
nos goûters et nos goûteuses avec plus
de la moitié des votes merci d'avoir
participé
[Musique]